we want to bring you the latest pictures
from the United States Delaware where
Joe Biden as you can see is starting his
trip to Europe there he is on to that
Seahawk helicopter it becomes Marine one
and he is on his way now he will go
um to Andrews Air Force Base and get on
to Air Force One as it will become and
he is due at Stansted Airport this
evening he will meet Rishi sunak and
tomorrow he'll head to Windsor where he
will meet the king he will then go to
Vilnius in Lithuania where that big NATO
Summit is being held and then after that
you'll head to Helsinki to welcome the
latest member of that NATO alliance
Finland but there we have it Marine One
on its way taking the US president
bringing him to the UK